bonsoir un nouveau numéro de municipal
2014 rendez-vous politique pour tout
savoir sur le prochain scrutin dans les
Yvelines sera question ce soir de la
nouvelle candidature du maire PS de Bois
d'Arcy claudevilliers il sera sur ce
plateau elle nous parlerons aussi de la
stratégie dans le département de l'UMP
avec Valérie Pécresse vous l'entendrez
au cours de ce numéro et puis nous irons
aussi à Voisins-le-Bretonneux ou
l'opposition commence à s'organiser
maison débute avec cette information
annoncée il y a quelques heures par
Christine Boutin sur son compte Twitter
puis reprise relayée par Jean-Luc
Trotignon conseiller municipal
d'opposition à Rambouillet Gérard
Larcher mer UMP de la ville depuis 30
ans ne sera pas candidat à sa propre
succession en mars prochain il laissait
planer le doute finalement cela semble
officiel vous aurez d'ailleurs
l'occasion d'entendre l'ancien ministre
l'ancien président du Sénat il sera
l'invité du journal de la rédaction ce
vendredi des 18 heures
en plateau ce soir je reçois Robert
Cadalbert président PS de la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin bonsoir
à bonsoir merci d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation je joue tout d'abord une
réaction peut-être concernant Gérard
Larcher qui a été maire pendant 30 ans
de cette commune de Rambouillet ne sera
pas candidat visiblement prochaine
scrutin
un homme un homme d'État et avec elle
beaucoup de choses se sont faits il
restera pas inactifs et sur le
département vous regrettez pas son
départ même si vous n'êtes pas de la
même tendance politique vous avez eu des
échanges avec Rambouillet non mais en
tous les cas moi je regarde je garderai
de Gérard Larcher c'est par exemple la
création de la Maison de l'emploi et la
Cité des Métiers qu'on a réussi à faire
à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines grâce à lui
Gérard Larcher qui reste sénateur des
Yvelines ça aussi il a annoncé Robert
casalbert vous êtes venus ce soir sur ce
plateau pour parler des changements à
attendre pour l'agglomération avec les
prochaines élections municipales et
notamment la représentativité au sein
des conseils communautaires de
l'agglomération sur les communes membres
mais déjà votre position peut-être à
vous pour ces élections vous êtes élu à
Guyancourt sur la liste de François de
Lignier vous si près une nouvelle fois
cette liste vous serez candidat aussi
comme je l'ai dit plusieurs fois mes
amis politiques oui je souhaite
continuer à assumer mes fonctions de
prise en agglomération pour assumer en
particulier une bonne transition de
cette exécutif qui aura lieu dans le
prochain mandat c'est-à-dire que vous
allez passer la main en cours de mandat
peut-être bien sûr bien sûr c'est prévu
vous savez déjà qui pour alors il faut
encore gagner ces élections municipales
il faut mettre un peu chaque chose en
son temps pour l'instant je ne suis
officiellement que ou je ne serai
officiellement que candidat sur la liste
d'union de la gauche du maire sortant
qui sera certaine de liste à Guyancourt
socialiste communiste
c'est à la tête de liste de gérer sa
liste et son équilibre Alice c'est
jamais quelque chose de très facile à
faire les élections aiguilles en cours
en général ne présentent pas beaucoup de
suspense on s'engage un petit peu mais
c'est aussi un constat 2008 73% des
suffrages exprimés sur la candidature de
gauche cette année qui présente un
militant plus jeune
comment vous vous abordez-vous cette
campagne effectivement je crois ce qui
est clair et vous vous êtes bien au
courant que la droite s'est fait un
objectif majeur c'est effectivement de
prendre l'avis nouvelle de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines même si et
nouvelle encore longtemps c'est 50 ans
de vie qui est l'objectif pour eux c'est
devenu insupportable qu'une réussite
telle importante que 50 ans de vie ne
soit pas dirigée par la globalement le
département est plutôt à droite
ça devient et quand vous écoutez Valérie
Pécresse et l'ensemble d'ailleurs ils
ont un objectif précis je vais pas dire
une obsession c'est prendre la vie
nouvelle et pour cela c'est ça qui est
important et ça va vous expliquer
pourquoi ma candidature a continué un
certain temps ces responsabilités est
important d'abord ils sont bien au
courant tout le monde est au courant que
normalement la plus grande probabilité
c'est que les mères qui sont en place
soient réunis
que ce soit à l'âge à la verrière ou
Bertrand Houillon à Manuel moire
intégrés dans leur ville et
effectivement font un excellent travail
dans leur ville donc la droite c'est
très bien que il y a pas beaucoup de
possibilités pour prendre cette vie
nouvelle comme ils disent et ils ont
essayé par différentes manœuvres en
particulier vous avez suivi aussi les
possibilités de faire rentrer des villes
de droite dans la terre communalité pour
qu'effectivement puisse faire changer la
majorité sans qu'il y ait pourtant un
projet un projet sur le territoire de
leur commune
émergent malheureusement dernièrement
ils ont fait une autre proposition j'ai
proposé moi-même à l'intercommunité que
ne change pas le nombre de délégués la
représentation
des communes à l'intercommunalité
municipal au-delà du changement de
majorité dans les communes c'est cette
représentativité des communaux va s'y
attarder juste pour finir sur sur
Guyancourt parce que je vous posais la
question vous n'êtes pas inquiet sur le
scrutin non non bien sûr que non la
ville restera détenue par
bien sûr mais tout ça c'est pas une
question de détenus parce qu'on détient
pas une vie c'est parce que on fait un
excellent travail depuis maintenant 30
ans Roland Dano a été maire en 1983 il y
a 30 ans ça fait 30 ans qui a un travail
efficace au service des habitants grâce
au développement économique et c'est
pour cela que effectivement lui en cours
est toujours à gauche on va parler donc
de l'agglomération et de cette question
de la représentativité des communes de
Saint-Quentin au sein de l'agglomération
on va avoir une infographie pour
comprendre peut-être un peu mieux la
question avec la nouvelle loi qui a été
votée au cours du scrutin municipal
dorénavant on désignera également nos
élus communautaires il y en a un certain
nombre avant le scrutin en 2014 il avait
a priori sur Montigny 8 sur sur
Élancourt 7 et vous le voyez en 2014 les
choses vont évoluer certaines communes
gagnent des représentants au Conseil
Communautaire les plus petites communes
en revanche en perde la verrière qui
passera de quatre à deux représentants
ça veut dire que les plus petites
communes auront encore moins de poids à
l'intérieur de l'agglomération de 50 ans
sur les prises de décision je reviens
sur ce que je disais qui est tout à fait
dans ce film là la volonté de la droite
de prendre la ville nouvelle
effectivement malgré parce que c'est une
réussite une réussite pourquoi parce
qu'effectivement je crois avoir pu
réussir à faire voter à l'unanimité
toutes les grandes décisions de
l'agglomération que ce soit
transformation de comité en comité
d'agglomération entrer dans l'opération
d'intérêt national toutes les communes
ont voté pour pareil pour le PLA pour
les budgets qui sont votés en général
sans opposition donc tout ça je crois
que je suis assez fier de pouvoir dire
tout ça a été fait à l'unanimité dans
cette dynamique et c'est cette dynamique
qui est le principal à tout du
territoire de Saint-Quentin de ville
sauf si effectivement j'ai fait une
proposition la dernière là effectivement
au mois de juin que on ne change pas la
représentation parce que dans les
possibilités
permet de maintenir c'est ce que j'ai
proposé qu'on maintienne et donc on
reste à 42 sièges avec un petit plus
pour mieux représenter les petites
communes qui s'intègrent et qui fasse un
excellent travail dans
l'intercommunalité la droite n'a pas
voulu donc on passe de 42 à 48 et pour
le 48 le nombre de délégués qui vient
qui sont
issus des communes de droite sera 24 le
nombre de délégués issus des communes de
gauche sera 24 vous voyez très bien avec
le nouveau système ce sont donc les
oppositions dans les communes lors du
scrutin municipal puisque ce scrutin
reste inscrite municipal au niveau des
communes c'est donc ces oppositions qui
feront une éventuelle majorité et c'est
je vous le dis franchement une deux
principales raisons de ma candidature
pour poursuivre un certain temps ces
fonctions de président d'agglomération
parce que fin mars je mets pas en doute
l'importance du vote démocratique qui
sera mais le résultat il sera qui sera
très serré on sera pas si animation
imagination ce projet un petit peu au
sein des différentes communes de
l'agglomération sur les sept communes
chacune des majorités est reconduite il
n'y a pas de changement tu as la tête
des communes sur les mers les
représentants les premiers magistrats en
revanche il y a une poussée de la droite
dans les communes qui sont détenus par
la gauche ça veut dire une plus forte
opposition éventuellement une
agglomération qui pourrait passer à
droite je ne sais pas en tous les cas
c'est pas bien sûr ne veut on fera tout
pour que ça soit pas en tous les cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que la majorité se
fera à une voix près ou pas de majorité
c'est ça et même pire il peut y avoir
des extrêmes qui sera élu de cette façon
là à l'Inter tonalité et celui qui
feront la loi à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines donc c'est
pour ça que ce important faut bien le
comprendre l'enjeu c'est pas l'enjeu
personnel de Robert Cadalbert c'est ça
fait longtemps que j'ai passé ce stade
là l'enjeu c'est comment on garde cette
réussite de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
cette stabilité vous savez la stabilité
c'est quelque chose c'est la confiance
quelque chose fondamentale pas
simplement pour les mères mais aussi et
d'abord pour la vie associative et
surtout pour le monde économique et pour
pour cette raison là il est important
pour moi je suis peut-être un peu fier
de le dire mais je peux représenter une
certaine stabilité et une image pour le
monde économique très important et c'est
pour cela en particulier que je souhaite
continuer un certain temps ces fonctions
pour assurer une bonne transition de
l'exécuter dans de bonnes conditions
dans ce prochain mandat c'est une
dernière question très rapidement
concernant ces municipal vous pensez que
les enjeux nationaux pourront déborder
sur les campagnes municipales il peut y
avoir une poussée de la droite bien sûr
c'est toujours possible c'est juste tout
marginal parce que les les habitants
sont attachés à leur mère c'est leur
mère qui généralement
politique bien sûr alors effectivement
c'est pour ça que c'était vraiment un
problème si l'agglomération qui a été
pacifié comme l'affaire Rolando et
lequel j'essaie de le faire que on a
effectivement cette dynamique cette
dynamique sur le territoire avec une
politique et pas simplement
c'est pas moi qui le dis c'est souvent
nos adversaires quand je vois toutes les
communes qu'il veut rentrer dans
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
de droite s'exprime aussi et parfois
exprime des désaccords bien sûr on n'est
pas toujours rose
prendre l'exemple où ça serait trop
facile dans un système manicien français
d'ailleurs
du fait certainement de l'élection
présidentielle où tout ce qui est bien
et d'un côté tout ce qui est le mal et
l'autre en tous les cas à
l'agglomération on ne gère pas une
intercommunité comme on gère une commune
puisque vous partez parler
d'intercommunalité on va s'intéresser à
ce sujet plus précisément on en a parlé
au cours des précédentes éditions du
journal de la rédaction les villes qui
ne l'ont pas encore fait qui ne font pas
encore partie d'intercommunalité vont
devoir se regrouper sous ce statut et
d'ici la fin de l'année le schéma
présenté par le préfet n'est pas du goût
de tout ça par exemple la ville des
Clayes-sous-Bois ne veut pas d'un
rapprochement qui a été décidé par
plaisir et Villepreux ce serait une
intercommunalité trop petite trop
coûteuse selon la mer Veronique côté
Milla Rudi elle va sans doute saisir un
cabinet d'avocats sur ce sujet on
l'écoute au micro de Catherine delatoo
vous pourrez réagir juste après notre
premier choix et 50 ans en Yvelines
parce que il y a une réalité il y a un
vrai bassin économique et qu'on a des
projets que nous pourrions monter
ensemble ensuite d'autant plus que 50
ans n'a pas encore at c'est 200 000
habitants ensuite vous avez la
communauté de Versailles Versailles
Grand Parc qui par contre eux ont
atteint ce seuil et puis est-ce qu'il y
aura des coupages et qu'on ira dans une
autre intercommunité je ne sais pas mais
j'allais dire notre premier choix
seraient 50 ans on a même commencé à
travailler sur un sur un projet
pour justement intégrer
l'intercommité de Saint-Quentin avec
avec bien sûr des villes de plaisir et
de vivre
Véronique qui souhaite intégrer 50 ans
en Yvelines encore aujourd'hui vous lui
répondez quoi mais d'abord que c'est pas
son premier choix Saint-Quentin et 8 son
premier choix c'est Versailles Grand pas
ses amis politiques le refusaient donc
après effectivement on est le deuxième
choix à Saint-Quentin de vie même si
c'est un bon deuxième choix en tous les
cas l'interprété c'est un état d'esprit
il faut savoir partager travailler
ensemble je crois que c'est une bonne
façon que même côté milliard s'entraîne
à travailler ensemble d'abord avec le
maire de plaisir les pères de millepreux
avant de rentrer dans une intercommité
mais encore une fois un atelier sur un
projet je le dis depuis deux fois qu'on
parle
cette candidature se souhait vous le
comprenez vous pourriez accepter vouloir
cette élargissement
vous adversaires politiques vont vous
dire vous ne voulez pas parce que ce
sont des communes de droite elle est
claire il est clair j'ai toujours dit
que on ne pouvait rentrer et réussir
comme à 50 ans en ligne parce qu'on est
sur un projet c'est l'État qui nous a
imposé un projet de vie nouvelle on a un
projet on a su faire vivre et réussir à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines donc c'est la
même chose je pense surtout les communes
de Maurepas
et de plaisir c'est quoi leur projet
nous on est dans un projet je disais
tout à l'heure j'ai fait adopter même si
ça n'était pas tout à fait d'accord de
rentrer dans l'opération internationale
les sept communes de l'agglomérations en
même temps morte pas et plaisir qui
était des communes voulues par le préfet
rentrer ils ont décidé de ne pas rentrer
dans cette opération Paris-Saclay
l'avenir de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
l'avenir de l'intercommunalité autour
doit se faire autour de ce projet
d'opération internationale
magnifique projet
d'avenir pour notre territoire et
l'avenir c'est aussi les élections
municipales ce sont donc les électeurs
qui se prononceront vers à Célia ou non
une poussée de la droite et quel
incident cela aura sur les conseils
communautaires le conseil communautaire
de l'agglomération merci Robert
Cadalbert président de cette
agglomération de Saint-Quentin et vous
serez candidat à Guyancourt bien sûr
pour un nouveau mandat aux côtés de
François de Ligny municipal 2014 qui se
poursuit nous ferons le point dans un
instant sur la candidature à gauche
chers Voisins-le-Bretonneux dans un
instant mais déjà des tours par la
fédération
UMP du département sa présidente Valérie
Pécresse a fait vous le savez de sa
priorité l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin la ville de
Magny-les-Hameaux elle était présente ce
week-end aux côtés d'Aurore berger à la
candidate qui se présente face au
socialistes Bertrand Houillon on en a
profité pour évoquer les ambitions de la
présidente de l'UMP dans le département
aujourd'hui toutes les villes sont des
priorités pour pour moi dans les
Yvelines parce que je pense que nous
avons fait nos preuves de bonnes gestion
dans ce département les Français veulent
venir vivre dans les Yvelines la plupart
des villes même des villes qui
sociologiquement sont des villes très
populaires sont gérés souvent par des
maires de droite qui font des villes
magnifiques qui gèrent j'allais dire de
manière économe efficace des services
publics performants bref je crois qu'il
fait bon vivre dans les villes
UMPS des Yvelines et donc toutes les
villes pour moi sont des villes qui
peuvent faire l'objet d'une véritable
alternance
et nous avons également profité de cette
venue de Valérie Pécresse pour la faire
réagir sur la sortie de son livre
voulez-vous vraiment sortir de la crise
il est sorti cette semaine et c'est un
inventaire des années Sarkozy voici sa
réaction c'est un livre de proposition
parce que ce que me disent tous les les
Yvelinois que je croise dans la rue il
me disent bon mais maintenant qu'est-ce
que vous proposez et puis quand je leur
dis ce que je propose il me disent mais
pourquoi vous l'avez pas fait avant donc
c'est un livre de proposition mais qui
s'appuie sur le bilan
l'inventaire du quinquennat précédent
l'inventaire parce que et bien il faut
comprendre pourquoi on n'a pas fait
certaines réformes et pourquoi il faut
les faire aujourd'hui la fusion du
département et de la région qui nous
fera économiser beaucoup d'argent la
baisse des charges sociales y compris
les charges payées par les salariés pour
qu'à la fin on est un salaire net plus
élevé et pour que ce soit plus
intéressant d'aller travailler plutôt
que de rester chez soi tout ça ce sont
des propositions qu'il faut qu'on mette
en œuvre on l'a pas fait avant et
j'explique pourquoi
un voisin le Bretonneux le maire UMP a
annoncé sa candidature à un quatrième
mandat en mars il était l'invité de
cette émission voici 15 jours et depuis
son opposition s'organise Jean hmmènera
bien une nouvelle campagne sous
l'étiquette d'hiver gauche avec le
soutien du parti socialiste face à ce
maire sortant l'annonce officielle se
fera dans quelques jours il s'attend à
scrutin difficile en 2008 sa liste avait
réuni quelques 28% alors qu'il était
opposé à trois candidats de droite
sociologiquement c'est que c'est
difficile puisque classiquement c'est du
60 40 pour la droite ceci étant moi je
ne veux absolument pas préjugés des
résultats des élections je fais
confiance aux électeurs et ça sera à
nous pendant la campagne d'essayer de
les convaincre que nous sommes prêts à
faire de voisins une ville ouverte et à
travailler uniquement pour les pour les
vies chinois mais tous les vicois alors
nous allons nous lancer courant des
cendres auparavant parce que on
considère que c'est pas la peine de
faire des campagnes très longues il faut
au contraire faire des campagnes
percutantes alors la liste est en cours
de constitution notre programme est en
cours d'affinage on n'a pas l'intention
de le diffuser trop vite parce qu'on a
souffert un peu dans le passé de
récupération je peux vous citer deux
actes qui vont être importants pour nous
d'un côté le logement je sais que ça
fait partie des actes biettes aussi
d'ailleurs mais le logement de façon à
ce qui parcourt résidentiel pour les
jeunes et les personnes plus âgées qui
utilisent la richesse de la mixité
sociale et qui permettent à chacun de
trouver de quoi se loger un voisin ça
c'est le premier aspect et le deuxième
aspect on veut faire de voisins une
ville exemplaire concernant les
préoccupations énergétiques
Claude viel le maire socialiste de
Bois-d'Arcy est à présent à l'éviter de
l'inviter de municipale 2014 bonsoir
merci répondu à notre invitation mère
depuis 18 ans et vous allez briguer un
nouveau mandat pourquoi cette
candidature
parce que d'abord je considère que on a
encore des des choses à réaliser on a
des projets il y a une ZAC et un projet
de cœur de ville et puis on a d'autres
projets mais je vais pas les énumérer
maintenant mais je souhaite
poursuivre d'abord également le travail
qui a été fait comme vous savez comme
vous savez on a beaucoup travaillé au
cours de ces de ces trois mandats sur
ces 18 ans mais il y a encore des choses
à réaliser et je pense que je suis en
capacité de de repartir pour un
quatrième mandat alors je vais donner
votre âge
oui absolument
vous a consacré une chronique suite à
votre déclaration de candidature on peut
y entendre une déclaration de votre
opposant de l'UMP Philippe benasaya qui
siège au conseil municipal dans
l'opposition je le cite le monde bouge
Claude via ne bouge pas vous lui
répondez quoi je bouge pas je peux pas
aller contre ce qui mais il est dans son
rôle probablement ceci étant je sais que
je ne suis plus je suis pas un jeune
homme mais alors il se trouve que je
suis en très bonne santé physiquement
intellectuellement les choses vont bien
donc je pense que je suis encore en
capacité d'assurer un mandat de maire là
je n'ai pas un critère qui rentre en
ligne de compte au moment de réfléchir à
votre objet
absolument réfléchi j'ai une femme des
enfants qui sont tous artisans les
petits-enfants donc ça fait l'objet de
d'un débat démocratique bien sûr en
vacances vous avez voté en famille pour
savoir si vous voulez candidats un peu
mieux que ça c'est pas suffrages à main
levé mais tout le monde j'ai décidé de
me présenter et j'ai l'accord de famille
c'est une chose non c'est pas ça c'est
que c'est pour la ville il y a encore
des choses et des projets à faire
avancer alors
j'attends vos questions du côté du PS on
parle du 10 octobre pour que les
militants désignent leur tête de liste
dans les différentes communes c'est la
règle pour tous c'est la voix de la
Fédération dans justement il y a juste
sur les communes de Montigny au plaisir
ou les investiront déjà été donnés ça
veut dire que les militants vont devoir
choisir si oui ou non vous serez
candidat alors attendez d'abord sur les
précédentes mandatures le
candidat de gauche était toujours été
présenté par le CLG peut-être vous
souvenez-vous le conseil local de la
gauche il en est de même pour cette
quatrième démarche que j'entreprends
alors l'investiture du PS j'ai toujours
eu je ne doute pas que j'aurai
l'investisseur des PS France Bleu je
reviens à cette chronique qui vous était
consacré aujourd'hui France Bleu qui
cite la fédération du PS apparemment ils
ont obtenu cette information selon
laquelle il reste une désignation rien
n'était joué en ce qui vous concerne de
toute façon de toute façon il y a un
vote des dans les sections le 10 octobre
bien évidemment mais vous êtes assuré
d'avoir cette majorité ah oui j'en ai
l'assurance oui et si vous ne l'aviez
pas vous serez candidat quand même même
sans l'investiture PS je suis présenté
par le Conseil local de la gauche ou à
la réponse
on va revenir sur ce scrutin on va
revenir en arrière 2008 premier tour 65%
des voix vous êtes donc à l'état
d'esprit avant d'entamer une nouvelle
campagne vous vous dites que les choses
seront faciles quand on est élu au
premier tour à 65% des suffrages et la
fois d'avant elle a fait 70 mais il y
avait ça réduit ceci dit il y avait une
une liste de
personnes qui avaient quitté le l'équipe
mais qui bon il se trouve qu'ils ont
fait 13% à l'époque on a fait 60 pas
tout à fait 65 et puis l'umpfl la
différence
65% donc vous êtes en quel état d'esprit
vous êtes une campagne facile
si jamais facile une campagne il faut
bon alors c'est vrai que l'équival le
maire de Bois-d'Arcy me semble-t-il
l'équipe les équipes on a une bonne
image sur cette ville puisque vous
parlez de vos équipes juin 2013 vous
avez écarté votre adjoint en charge du
développement durable puisque vous
l'avez accusé d'avoir faussé une
procédure d'appel d'offres
un prétexte c'est son point de vue mais
vous avez pu éventuellement vous sentir
menacé par sa candidature pour les
musulmans
toute la liberté s'il veut monter au
créneau je sais mais je souhaite pas
revenir sur cette sur cette affaire
j'avais été extrêmement discret il a cru
utile de de faire appel à la presse et
que ceci dit au sein d'une équipe comme
un adjoint et mise à l'écart ça peut
créer des tensions au sein d'une équipe
comment se passe actuellement la
situation dans votre majorité dans votre
ville
les conseils municipaux ont lieu le PLU
était adopté dans le cadre de votre
candidature vous repartirez avec la même
équipe que la liste est déjà plus ou
moins définie
la liste n'est pas encore comment
difficile et je repartirai avec un
nombre
important de personnes qui sont en
situation d'adjoie déjà qui siège déjà
une très bonne équipe et je pense que il
y a aucune raison pour que ceux qui ont
travaillé avec moi pendant 6 ans on a ma
compagne pas si vous êtes élu est-ce que
vous ferez votre mandat jusqu'à la fin
jusqu'à son terme excusez-moi
la réponse si je pars je suis en bonne
santé c'est pour assurer
mon mandat mais on m'a déjà fait la même
un petit
une parenthèse on m'a déjà fait la
dernière fois la même critique
précisément par les deux disques étaient
en face de moi et il se trouve que les
deux têtes de liste de ces
2008 on peut au conseil municipal ont
démissionné
toujours là donc ceci c'est pas une
critique
vous êtes est-ce que vous avez besoin si
vous êtes élu en 2014 enfin non si je
suis en bonne santé si ma santé le
permet c'est bien évident alors à l'abri
d'un pépin de santé c'est général au
précédent scrutin vous avez passé la
main vous n'êtes pas reprocher vous
n'aviez pas c'est la main et puis en
effet on peut pas être partout il y
avait la terre communauté de versa grand
parc etc donc je vais considérer qu'il
fallait que je me dégage du du conseil
général ce que j'ai fait on aura
l'occasion de revenir au cours des
prochains numéros de cette émission
municipale 2014 les différents projets
différents débats seront organisés sur
ce plateau avec les différents candidats
des communes du département mais votre
projet repose sur quoi pour 2014
la croix bonnet qui est en zone
effectivement beaucoup de construction
on peut le voir quand on passe par la
maison d'entreprise et cetera bien et
puis on a entre autres effectivement un
gymnase pour le collège on a le centre
technique municipal qu'on va délocaliser
et mettre sur la croix bonnet et puis on
a un projet piscine avec en inter dans
le cas d'une intercommunalité avec la
ville de Fontenay et puis effectivement
le cœur de ville vous avez raison
une affaire importante on va voter le 19
novembre prochain la ZAC et puis là on
stoppe provisoirement les choses et puis
il appartiendra à l'équipe qui sera en
place fin mars de d'avancer sur ce
projet mais effectivement ça sera c'est
un jeu de la campagne ce cœur de ville
je vous le dire
d'être venu candidat socialiste en mars
2014 mère sortant pour un nouveau mandat
fin de ce numéro de municipal 2014
prochain rendez-vous politique sur
téléfilm dans une quinzaine de jours 1er
octobre je recevrai le candidat du Front
de Gauche à Magny-les-Hameaux Raymond
Besco ainsi que François de lign Ier le
merps2 Guyancourt qui brillera en mars
lui aussi un nouveau mandat rendez-vous
dans 15 jours les programmes se
poursuivent sur téléfil